okay if you're thinking about applying
for a PhD ask yourself a question why
you would like to do that and if the
answer is because you're really
interested in the topic and you're
really interested in doing research on
that topic
then do a PhD don't do it because you
think it's a good you know career move
I'm afraid research is a kind of long
term it's a long game and it doesn't
quickly reward you but it is immensely
rewarding in the long term this is a
very negative first thing to say but
make sure you actually want to do a PhD
because a PhD is 3 to 4 years of hard
work blood sweat and tears it's a period
of time which okay I had a great time
during my PhD it was fantastic but a PhD
is very very challenging you'll
basically cast out into the wilderness
and you have to support your soup from
your supervisors but fundamentally it's
your work and there will be times and I
don't know a PhD student who didn't have
these times where you'd have a clue what
to do
the point is you're doing research so
your supervisor to act or what to do
because they don't know the answers if
they knew the answers then why are you
doing it so there are things that you do
the answers to you don't know what to do
you don't even have a clue where to
start addressing this problem and you'll
want to go home and cry and I think most
PhD students have gone home and cried I
sort of think a PhD is mainly about
learning how to sniff out a dead end
doesn't come really positive but it's
sort of sort of what it is it's like
okay can this person work out as a dead
end before their forehead starts to
bleed that's what I think I got it
and also the flip side to that is can
you work out when you're going down a
dead-end there's a little part that
looks interesting through the bushes and
allow yourself to explore that because
that's the best researchers are not
blinkered in that sense they often have
an idea in front of them but they will
also be opportunistic so they're going
along and they look down on the ground
living a little since I might go there
for a little while
or my send someone else that way another
PhD student away or something we'll go
exploring that if you do want to do your
PhD then that's great and despite all
the kind of negative stuff I said about
doing a PhD I had a fantastic time and
it is that the most uniquely rewarding
experience I can think of because you're
doing research that you set presumably
you like what you're doing otherwise why
are you doing it and so being able to
have all of that free time to just work
on what interests you is a tremendous
privilege and I'm so I feel so happy
that I had the opportunity and I feel so
happy that I'm doing that right now
most PhD interviews are not particularly
full so really what the supervisor is
looking for is someone who clearly shows
interested interest in the topic and and
again is willing to discuss discuss
things in depth and challenge the sort
of perceived wisdom and challenge
existing ideas other stuff to think
about when you're applying for PhD is
the stuff that I don't think people do
consider quite as much which is going to
be think about the topic of their PhD is
this does this topic interest me that's
important but also think about the
environment the university will offer
you because universities don't tend to
treat PhD students that well they see
them this I mean as a PhD student you're
pretty much at the bottom of the
ecosystem in the university other than
undergraduates but I mean they're just
so low that if you people have people's
time pretend they don't exist so as a
PhD student the university tries
technology but at a bare minimum level
and that means that lots of the
facilities for PhD students might not be
that good you might be stuck in a very
large office with lots of people you
don't know maybe from different
disciplines might even get an office
lots of humanities PhD students don't
and that can be a very isolating
experience so it's important to check
whether your university has the
appropriate support structures in place
talk to existing students past students
existing students will probably give you
a negative view past students will give
you a positive view and supervisors
supervisors are very different in the
way they deal with students some are
very hands-off
you're on your own and see you in three
years not quite that bit close to that
and others will be quite prescriptive
and what they want and for some people
the ones that sit you down and said this
is what I expect to do by next week are
the best sort of thing and for others
it's just leave me alone so if you don't
have access to an office deal access to
other collaborative spaces where you can
meet people also doing PhDs are they in
your subject area which is great for
improving your research and also non
your subject area just for keeping you
sane so it's good to have access to
these kind of spaces where you can meet
other people and stop yourself going mad
because if doing a PhD can be a very
isolating experience if you don't have
these kind of support structures the
whole process of applying for a PhD is a
bit it is a bit kind of random in a
sense how do you find a place you know
how do you know what you're interested
in a non-traditional 'evil because
research can be many steps removed from
the sorts of topics and people do it
undergraduate and the best PhD students
you tend to find are people who you
either know because you've taught them
or you know because someone you know was
talking taking someone you don't know
very well is it's always a bit of a risk
but you know so so if you have already
have a relationship you've had some
interaction with one of your lecturers
at university ask them if they've got
any PhD places if you're interested in a
subject they're doing and they make they
might have some now that layer between
ten kilometers and fifty comms announced
to you is what we call a stratosphere
and it accounts for almost the entirety
of the remaining mass of the atmosphere
see ya let's see if I can remember this
or if you want more background videos
with John and I just talking about stuff
then please comment below make sure you
go and look at that singing playlist of
choral music about Christmas comment
below which one piece is your favorite
you know just have a listen to a few and
shuffles